[Music]
in 2004 a new company called vemma
nutrition started offering a
life-changing opportunity to earn
full-time income for part-time work
vemma's offer was open to everybody
regardless of prior experience or
education
there are only two steps to get started
earning purchase a five hundred to six
hundred dollar kit of their liquid
nutrition products and recruit two more
members to do the same
vemma nutrition company grew quickly
becoming a global operation that brought
in 30 000 new members per month at its
peak
there was just one problem while the
company generated 200 million dollars of
annual revenue by 2013 the vast majority
of participants earned less than they
paid in
vemma was eventually charged with
operating a pyramid scheme a common type
of fraud where members make money by
recruiting more people to buy in
typically the founder solicits an
initial group of people to buy in and
promote the scheme they are then
encouraged to recruit others and
promised part of the money those people
invest while the founder also takes a
share
the pattern repeats for each group of
new participants with money from recent
arrivals funneled to those who recruited
them this differs from a ponzi scheme
where the founders recruit new members
and secretly use their fees to pay
existing members who think the payments
come from a legitimate investment
as a pyramid scheme grows it becomes
increasingly difficult for new recruits
to make money that's because the number
of participants expands exponentially
take a structure where each person has
to recruit six people to earn a profit
the founder recruits six people to start
and each of them recruits six more there
are 36 people in that second round of
recruits who then each recruit six
people a total of 216 new recruits
by the 12th round of recruiting the 2.1
billion newest members would have to
recruit over 13 billion more people
total to make money more than the entire
world population in this scenario the
most recent recruits over 80 percent of
the schemes participants lose all the
money they paid in
and in real life many earlier joiners
lose out too
pyramid schemes are illegal in most
countries but they can be difficult to
detect
they're presented as many different
things including gifting groups
investment clubs and multi-level
marketing businesses
the distinction between pyramid schemes
and legitimate multi-level marketing can
be particularly hazy in theory the
difference is that the members of the
multi-level marketing companies
primarily earn compensation from selling
a particular product or a service to
retail customers while pyramid schemes
primarily compensate members for
recruitment of new sellers
in practice though many multi-level
marketing companies make it all but
impossible for members to profit purely
through sales and many pyramid schemes
like vemma nutrition disguise themselves
as legal multi-level marketing
businesses using a product or service to
hide the pay and recruit structure
many pyramid schemes also capitalize on
already existing trust within churches
immigrant communities or other tightly
knit groups the first few members are
encouraged to report a good experience
before they actually start making a
profit
others in their network follow their
example and the schemes balloon in size
before it becomes clear that most
members aren't actually profiting often
the victims are embarrassed into silence
pyramid schemes entice people with a
promise of opportunity and empowerment
so when members don't end up making
money they can blame themselves rather
than the scheme thinking they weren't
tenacious enough to earn the returns
promised some victims keep trying
investing in multiple schemes and losing
money each time
in spite of all these factors there are
ways to spot a pyramid scheme
time pressure is one red flag be wary of
directives to act now or miss a once in
a lifetime opportunity promises of large
life-altering amounts of income are also
suspect
and finally a legitimate multi-level
marketing business shouldn't require
members to pay for the opportunity to
sell a product or service
pyramid schemes can be incredibly
destructive to individuals communities
and even entire countries
but you can fight fire with fire by
sending this video to three people you
know and encouraging them to do the same
while we're at it here are a couple
other things we can help you keep an eye
out for
[Music]
you